كما تجتمع هذا اليوم للاستماع الى دوله
اسرائيل وهي تقدم مرافعتها الشفهيه اليوم
بموجب الطلب الخاص بال اجراءات الاحترازيه
التي قدمتها دوله جنوب افريقيا في 29 من
ديسمبر 2023 فيما يتعلق بتطبيق اتفاقيه
منع الاباده الجماعيه والمعاقب عليها في
قطاع غزه قضيه جنوب افريقيا ضد اسرائيل
والان احيل الكلمه للقاضي ممثل دوله
اسرائيل تفضل الكلمه لك
السيده
الرئيسه الاعضاء
الموقر من دواعي شفي ان امثل امامكم مره
اخرى بالنيا ممثلا لدوله
اسرائيل ان دوله اسرائيل
تدرك لماذا اتفاقيه منع الاباده الجماعيه
والتي تم تفعيلها في هذه الاجراءات تم
تبنيها في المقام
الاول وهي راسخه في ذاكرتنا والقتل
المنهجي ل 6 ملايين يهودي كجزء من برنامج
متعمد مقصود
لاباده الشعب اليهودي وعلى ضوء تاريخ
الشعب اليهودي
ونصوصه التوراتيه فانه من غير المفاجا ان
اسرائيل ان اول دوله صادقت على تلك
الاتفاقيه وانضمت اليها دون تحفظات كانت
اسرائيل
وادخلت احكامها وموادها في تشريعاتها
وقانونها
الداخليه على وعد ان ذلك يشمل جميع الناس
وهذا شعار لاسرائيل وبالنسبه لاسرائيل هذا
هو اعلى التزام قانوني رف لمكن وهو يهودي
بولندي
شهد الترويع الهائل في الهولوكوست
ساعد العالم على ادراك ان
وجود مصطلحات قانونيه غير كافيه
للاحاطة
ان معاناه المدنيين في هذه الحرب كحال كل
الحروب الاخرى امر
ماساوي ويؤلم القلب ويفطر والحقيقه
المؤلمه للاعمال العدائيه الحاليه جعلت من
المؤمن مؤمن بمكان بنسبه لمدنيين على ضوء
استراتيجيه التي تتبعها حماس وذلك من اجل
تعظيم عدد المدنيين القتلى في صفوف
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين في الوقت الذي
تسعى فيه في اسرائيل الى الحد من عدد
هؤلاء القتلى ولكن المحكمه اوضحت ان
اتفاقيه منع الاباده الجماعيه لم يتم
تصميمها للنظر
في
التاثير الوحشي على المدنيين حتى عندما
يكون استخدام القوه يرفع او يثير قضايا
جسيمه وجديه في القانون الدولي ويؤدي الى
معاناه هائله واستمرار لسقوط
ضحايا ان الاتفاقيه تم وضعها و للتصدي
للجرائم الرهيبه ذات الجسامه الاستثناء
غير الاستثنائيه نحن نعيش في عالم الكلام
فيه رخيص في عالم وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
فان رغبه للبحث عن مصطلحات تشيطن و الطرف
الاخر اصبحت امرا لا يمكن
مقاومته ولكن لو كان هنالك مكان تعني فيه
الكلمات والمصطلحات شيء وان الحقيقه ما
زالت مهمه فانها ستكون في محكمه
القانون مقدمه الدعوه للاسف وضعت امام هذه
المحكمه صوره مشوهه
ومغلوطة
جنوب افريقيا اختارت ان تاتي الى هذه
المحكمه بزعم انها حاميه وراعيه للانسانيه
ولكن من خلال نزع الشرعيه عن وجود اسرائيل
منذ 75 عاما في كلمتها الافتتاحيه
امس جعل الالتزام تجاه الانسانيه فارغا
اجوف ووصفها غير الحقيقي للنزاع الفلسطيني
الاسرائيلي يبدو انه اثار
التاريخ اليهودي
والمسؤوليه ان نزع الشرعيه عن
اسرائيل منذ انشائها في عام
1948 في طلب
الدعوه لا يفرق بين رفض حماس لخطابها من
غير
المفاجئ انه في
سرد مقيمه الدعوه فيما يتعلق ب يحصل في
غزه حيث تم نزع الصفه الانسانيه عن
اسرائيل ان محاوله استخدام الاباده
الجماعيه كسلاح في النص
الحالي يعرض صوره مشوهه للغايه لما يحدث
بكلمات جوفاء يخرجها من سياقها ومن
معانيها الاصيله وهو يشير الى وهو يضر
بهدف هذه الاتفاقيه
وما ترتبط بذلك من تداعيات سيما الدول
التي تحاول الدفاع عن نفسها والتي تحاول
ان تحافظ على الحياه وتحمي القانون السيده
الرئيس الاعضاء الموقر يوم السبت السابع
من اكتوبر وهو يوم عيد وهو عطله دينيه
اسرائيليه مقاتل
حماس اقتحموا الاراضي الاسرائيليه
وسيادتها برا و جوا
واقتحموا مواقع
وحفلات بع ذلك تحت غطاء الاف الصواريخ
التي اطلقت وبشكل عشوائي تجاه اسرائيل هو
مذبحه هائله وتقطيع اوصال واغتصاب
واختطاف لاكبر عدد ممكن من المواطنين عثر
عليهم الارهابيون قبل ان ترد القوات
الاسرائيليه هم عذبوا الاطفال امام ذويهم
والاباء والامهات امام ابنائهم وحرقوا
الناس بما في ذلك رضع احياء وقاموا ب شكل
منهجي اغتصاب
وقتل عدد كبير من النساء والاطفال في
الاجمال 1200 شخص ذبحوا في ذلك اليوم
واكثر من
و240 شخصا تم اختطافهم بما في ذلك اطفالا
رضع وعائلات باكملها ومن ذوي الاعاقه و
ذلك ناجون من الهولوكوست بعضهم تم اعدامه
بعضهم تم اعدامهم منذ ذاك والكثير منهم
تعرضوا للتعذيب
والاعتداء الجنسي
والحبس
الانفرادي ممثلوا عائلات الرهان موجودون
معنا في هذا في هذه المحكمه و ندرك مدى
معاناتهم نحن نعرف ان الوحشيه في السابع
من اكتوبر ليس فقط من شهادات المروعه
للناجين و
ل الذبح والوحشيه التي تركها الارهابيون
وكذلك الادله الجنائيه التي رفعت
من المكان ان نعرف ان المعتدين قاموا بفخر
بتصوير ما فعلوه ان احداث ذلك
اليوم تم تجاهلها بالكامل في الدعوه
المرفوعه
ولكننا ملزمون
بمشاركه المحكمه بعض ذلك الترويع وذلك
العنف واكبر عدد من اليهود الذين سقطوا
منذ الهلوس نفعل ذلك ليس لان تلك الاعمال
رغم
منهجيتها تحلل اسرائيل من التزامها بشان
الحفاظ على القانون وهي تدافع عن شعبها
ودولتها لا نحن نفعل ذلك لانه من اصعبه
بمكان فهم النزاع المسلح في غزه دون تقدير
طبيعه التهديد الذي تواجهه اسرايل
والوحشيه
والعدوانيه التي
تحملها يحملها عدوها وفي المواد وفي
الدعوه انا ملزم لعرض للعرض امام المحكمه
بعض
المشاهد ل الوحشيه التي لا يمكن
تصورها التي جرت في مئات المواقع في ذلك
اليوم
الفضيع جيمي سمنوف وهو مزارع وزوجته
تمارا ناشطه في الدفاع عن حقوق النساء
تعيشوا في كيبوتس نيروز عندما بدا اطلاق
الصواريخ لجوا مع
ابنهم وال التوام اربيل وشخر الى المج
خلال
العمليه اشعل مقاتل حماس بيتهم
و سمعوا
كانوا يختنقون اثناء احتراق المنزل
والعائله
برمتها ماتت
حرقا ما جعل التعرف على هويتهم من خلال
الدي ان ايه والحمض النووي صعب للغايه ان
اجون من مذبحه الحفل
الموسيقي راوا مقاتل حماس وارهابهم يقومون
باغتصاب احدى السيدات ويقطعون ثديها
ومقاتل اخر اغتصبها مره اخرى
واطلق النار عليها
في راسها وهو يجامعها
و في
تقرير احد مقاتلي حماس القى قنبله يدويه
في مكان لجا اليه اب وابنه وابنيه قتل
الاب وجرح الابنان ونزف دما احد الاطفال
سمعناه يصيح و
على شقيقه يقول لماذا بقيت حيا لا ارى
شيئا
سيقتلوننا المقاتل فتح البراد واخرج
قاروره المياه وقام بشربها ثم هنالك
تسجيلا من كيبوت
ميم
pr